okay i'll back up
definitely an adrenaline rush after a
lifetime in the woods
it's not too often that i'm caught with
my pants down
but some things you just have to seek to
believe
once a year the lone moose
throws a party
this is crazy
then all hell breaks loose
that was insane
no one knows why the super group porn
but if i'm embedded in a gang this
dangerous i can smell their breath i
need to go
undercover
this is america the wild
look at this stuff it's amazing that
these
moose can actually
get through this stuff
i mean these are
giant
critters and they totally
just plow through this willow
and i come around to this thick thick
willow bottle
and right in front of me at first i
think it's a pile of bones look at this
maybe i found some shed loose antlers
this is not a shed antler
it is unbelievable what i find
this is unbelievable
look at that look at this
these are heavy massive horns and skulls
here this thing has been sitting here
for a very long time you can see all the
moss and liking on it
oh
this thing is so
heavy dude check this out look at this
let's just cut through those willows
cutting through the willows and this was
just buried all tangled
this
is where two big bull moose
got locked together during a fight
and that's the way they died
moose mating season
two prime bulls
each weighing in at 1500 pounds
antlers the size of snowplows
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to imagine but these guys have
so much force as hard as this antler
looks it actually has a bit of give a
little bit of flex
so all that force and flex just enough
and when they get their hands together
and lock them together forever
look at
this completely
locked
and the only thing cooler than finding
this
is to actually
have front row seats to one of these
battles
got a great fresh gift of snow on the
ground so it's a perfect situation to
cut some moose tracks i've got several
sets of moose prints right here in the
snow just kind of coming down from the
high country down into this
massive willow flat
this is one of the most hidden places in
all of montana
the centennial
a place i've never been
normally only see a handful moose all
year
word on the street
is that the centennial valley is moose
mecca
i've got this inner state of moose
with these merging wolves and deer and
elk
look how cool this is right here
predator
prey
right together
and they're headed right down there into
those willows
and one way you can tell
the freshness of the track is if you
find scat like i just did here and if
you just squish it between your fingers
you can tell if it's soft it's fresh if
it's hard it's not so fresh but there's
another way
[Music]
you know there's only one
more thing you can do
a little frontier
sweet
so i'm guessing
well
anywhere between
well
yeah about 45 to an hour
so this moose was definitely
just through here
hmm man it's almost got like a
caramel filling
because it does look here scat not scat
scat not scat
little candy treat
now i'm gonna follow these moose
i'm really gonna pay attention cause i
don't wanna step right on a moose in
here and this stuff is thick
in all my years in montana
i've been charged by a grizzly bear less
than i have by moose
[Applause]
right here
is a cow and a calf
when it comes to protecting their calf
a moose cow will come right after you
and put the hooves to you
so this time of year i still carry my
bear spray but now it turns to moose
spring
i'm just gonna try to sneak in
now i'm playing chicken with a mama
moose and that's not a smart thing to do
but her ears are still forward and i'm
watching for her to start to pin her
ears back her hackles that go up and if
that happens my safety trigger is coming
off my bear spray
they're pretty aware they're pretty
skittish
[Music]
and the calf are out of here
it's amazing an animal that big can just
disappear
[Music]
so i started looking around
i glass what i think at first is like a
herd of cows
wow there is a ton of moose out there
then when i looked at my binoculars it
blows my mind
seven adult moose
so this is really crazy there's
seven moose out here four bulls three
cows out on this wide open flat grass
in an in order for me to actually sneak
up closer to them i'm gonna use this
this ditch here
it's like i mean it's like i'm sneaking
up on a grizzly bear out in the middle
of a meadow in yellowstone it's so weird
the moose the largest member of the deer
family is not known for being hurt
but once a year at the peak of the rut
everything changes
it's a rare thing called a super group
when up to 30 moose come together
it's like a mirage
and everything i know about moose is out
the window
and this is
first for me absolute first
if i can get in the middle of the herd
there's a chance that i can see behavior
that
nobody's ever seen before
i don't really know what to expect
here's an
animal that's notorious
for being aggressive
now i've got a hurdle
i've got seven individual personalities
[Music]
a bunch of bad dudes
these moves could come over
and you can see
there's not a tree for me to climb
is this crazy
i think so
most of them
are watching me
during the mating season these guys were
fighting
now they're so exhausted that they don't
even see each other as a threat
but what does that make me
[Music]
as i approached they treat me just like
any other predator
[Music]
busted
i'm glad they chose flight over fight
this really inspires me to try to get in
the middle of the herd to try to get
close and learn more about these animals
for me to get in that herd is going to
be impossible because they're they feel
threatened but during the rut their
minds are on other things they're our
minds on mating and that'll be a perfect
opportunity while they're distracted to
get in the middle of the herd
i missed my shot to get inside a super
group but i know a place where i might
get a second chance
alaska
that's just crazy right here in the
middle of town
the rut is going down i mean this big
bull has found this cow he's watching it
pretty crazy
alaska moose are the biggest in the
world and i know exactly where to find
these giants
but it might not be where you expect wow
this is cool it's like a museum this is
nice taxidermy
as soon as i get to russell's shop i can
see he's quite an artist
and i've been a taxidermist
since
1973. he's like albert einstein of the
taxidermy world that's drank way too
much moonshine i took a mail order
course through the mail a dollar a month
so i mean obviously you've got this art
gap making
this look as real as possible what am i
doing here well i've got a crazy idea to
get myself into the middle of a super
group and russell
he's the only guy for the job knights
texting is known for first and this is
going to be a first i can
see horns
wheels
and possibly blood involved
wow this is like a factory back here
yeah this is uh this is my little shot
let's see what you got
well let's go ahead around the corner
you ready i'm ready
around the corner and bang right there a
giant bull moose strapped
to the front of a four-wheeler
this is gonna be awesome
or really dumb
here he goes hurry up hurry up he's
coming
watch my back
this is probably the most dangerous time
of year for moose
um in especially in urban areas we live
in anchorage it's kind of like a threat
you gotta live with it seems impossible
but moose injure more alaskans every
year than bears
[Music]
so i need some expert advice it's a time
of year where you really need to pay
attention to what's going on around you
and there's one person that takes all
the calls
jesse coltrane
oh musa literally stand
at the edge of the woods and you may not
see them but they know when you've
stepped one step too close
and that's when they're gonna come at
you
jesse takes me to one of anchorage's big
city parks
and sure enough we walk right up on a
massive cow
close together
she's really watching this cow and it's
got me a little nervous because jesse
knows her moose
always go backwards right
it's the last thing we want right now is
heard a chart come over and put the
hooves to us
[Music]
in a moose super group i could be
dealing with 20 cows
if i can't handle just one
i'm in trouble
wow she's uh as big as the biggest moose
in montana
this is not that big
she's probably average
and look at that bait that head's gotta
be their heads are huge
[Music]
they're very sad
oh yeah there's tracks everywhere in
here what the heck happened here this is
a really cool running pitch you smell
that yeah it was very very plunging well
that's um that's moose p
so the bulls make these pits and they
dig it all up with their hooves and then
they
they pee in it and they then they splash
themselves with the pee they get it on
their antlers and this is all to attract
the ladies so it's like muscular it's
yes
in a sick pee kind of way yeah
this is a moose magnet and it not only
does it attract cow moves but it also
tracks other bulls
the pull of the rut draws in up to 30
hormone crazed moose
that's the alaskan super group and
that's what i'm after
and when i find it i'm going in
[Music]
i can't go head to head with a moose
but bullwinkle my experimental moose
decoy
[Music]
he's the ultimate weapon to unlock the
secrets of the moose front
so you know it's so important to pay
attention to detail in these moose
mountains but especially for casey
because he's going to want his moose to
be convincing
yeah this is about a 65-inch bull moose
this is uh what we consider a trophy
bull so i've got this crazy idea to
understand moose ruddy behavior
and it all starts with the antler
the moose antler is amazing
i mean it looks like two giant satellite
dishes this big palmated antler on
either side of its head and it's used
for so many things
they communicate with each other they
fight with each other they do this
beautiful display to each other to
either attract or deter
i made these you know you said you
needed to be able to put three different
sizes on so i made them so so you can
see how they work they'll just they
slide right off
so this rack right here is the is the
medium-sized rack okay but let me show
you the other pair i got for you so
here's the million-dollar question
how do these things actually work in
battle here's your side
whoa look at that that's a big guy yeah
and here's my side russell has made the
moose with three sizes of
interchangeable antlers little tiny guys
medium ones and big massive ones and
here's my side and you just me again you
just lift them up and you kind of gotta
gotta kind of line them up to be able to
get them on
meat bullwinkle a weapon
of moose destruction
it's time to get this new mobile here we
go
as i pull out of the garage with this
giant moose rack and head strapped on
the front of a four-wheeler
i think
this might be the craziest thing i've
ever done
[Music]
when it comes to studying moose there's
no better place to get up close than
here in alaska's kenai moose research
center
macau moose comes into estrus for only
18 to 24 hours and that moment is now
and lenny here is hardwired to know that
and he's the biggest most mature bull
here at
and he is
focused on his girlfriend over here
across the way
if there wasn't a fence in the way he'd
be over there
and that makes it prime time for my
experiment there's a new bull in town
lenny
i've got the perfect moose decoy now i
gotta add a little scent to the seam
the best way to do that is to find a rut
pit
so i'm looking around here and trying to
find one if i find one i'm gonna dig up
the stinky mud put it in this bag apply
it to my scene hopefully it adds to the
attraction
how many bulls do we have in this pin
[Music]
one they gotta keep your eye out for
the actual running moose
that's a little bit uh
added danger to this game
hide and seek got an incoming bull he's
a little bit
quicker pace than i like to see last
thing we want to do is be messing with a
bull's butt pit while he
he's already feeling a little aggressive
[Music]
all righty
we got woolwinkle here at the kenai
peninsula ready for some moose
interaction
so first off
i'm gonna bring the mobile moose in here
to meet her gert
now gert is an estrus
she's a female and if everything works
out right she's gonna fall in love with
the new addition
you ready to meet your new boyfriend
[Music]
lenny
has got
his
sights on his latest competition
this has got to be a concern to him it's
a bigger
badder moose in his girlfriend's house
so this is looking pretty good i know
the cow's in here and i've been
somewhere i don't see her but i know
she's close
i've got to do one thing now i've got to
add some scent to the experiment here's
the mud from the right pit and this
stuff
stinks
this is for the ladies
that's looking pretty good
smelling pretty good
now
just sit back and wait
[Music]
so i get my decoy into position and gert
is nowhere to be found
i get up and start looking around and
the good thing is that i have russell
watching the situation too and if i get
approached by a moose you know he can
give me the heads up you have any
sighting of email
i've been looking and looking and i
don't see the female yet
could be any minute though
maybe our moose is ugly
i don't think our moose is ugly
but i just think he's so handsome that
maybe she's scared away
lenny is coming down towards us so i'm
assuming
he's got his eyes fixed on surprise
keep your eyes open because i think that
gal might be near
we've got two bulls now on the adjacent
pen
the competition is starting to heat up
[Music]
i'm seeing movements
yes she's slowly heading
here
she's got him spotted okay she's making
her move darts
right now
[Music]
gurt gets in close
oh i see her
definitely sees our decoy
[Music]
and then
she turns and runs the other direction
i told you that moose was ugly
i'm a bit disappointed i thought it was
handsome
moose calf rodeo bottle feed whatever
you want to call it it's gonna be rowdy
gert's giving our decoy the cold
shoulder
oh here they come look at them
but i wanna see the results after a date
goes well
it's like i'm using my uh football
skills here
spin move
this is fun
if you look at these guys
you know one thing about a moose they're
kind of like alaska's giraffe
look at the long legs long face they can
reach up
and at only a
few months old these guys are strong and
look how big they are
nearly as tall as i am
it's a very vulnerable time
for moose cavs out in the wild
over 50 percent of moose cavs die in
their first year and it could be wolves
grizzly bears weather they have a lot of
things going against them 50 seems
pretty high
then i see this footage from denali
national park
these wolves are in hunt mode
i bet this cow could run away but she's
got that little cat to protect
wolves love chaos
this is their mind
now the mom and catherine under the
water this could be the only chance
[Applause]
ultimate
but in the end there's just too many
wolves
it's heartbreaking but this really is
just a day in the life of an alaskan
moose camp
survival's a long shot
but a super group might be nature's way
of beating the odds
i've gotta go to the wilds of denali to
find out
[Music]
so when the sun goes down that's when
the action really heats up
i've got at least
three or four cows right here and a big
bull slipping in behind
i can see it's rat coming through the
trees right here
it's just being this close
to these massive
animals in the dark is pretty awesome
to be out in the middle of the night
during the height of the moose rut at
its highest level of activity is amazing
now i've got this thermal imaging camera
but i can actually watch it all go down
look at the size of this guy
he's just focused on these females
trying to find which one's going to give
in
and right now they're not real
interested this guy is
humongous
he's ready for a battle for sure
and i can hear it
breaking branches snorting groaning and
it's all around me
he's coming our way i'm gonna back out
he's a pissed off dude right now he's
he's looking around he's looking for
chicks he's looking for a fight
and i don't want to be
the guy he picks look at the side of
this
look at that he's as big as one lane of
the highway
the bull's off to find the super group
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
look at this
really fresh
wolf cat
and all through it is moose hair
i know i've got moose in the area maybe
even wolves this is getting really
awesome
[Music]
well looks like i'm gonna have to get
wet gotta get my boots off my socks take
my pants off too
[Applause]
don't get too jealous
that's cool
quite a ways away
i see
definitely a bull moose there's some
other animals around pride cows i can't
tell but i can see his rack
just these like
light colored reflecting right back at
my eyes right here just
huge rack
i start scanning
there's some moose over here some moose
over there
then i hit the main group the entire
hillside is covered with them
this has to be the super group
look at that
i need to get up on that hill now
it's thick in here
and this little bull's got me pegged
he's looking right at me
he definitely knows i'm coming
check this out
this little bull
has been
practicing
with his antlers
the big battle he might have
you can see he's taking it out
on this first tree
hopefully he doesn't want to come over
and practice on me
this is getting crazy he's not moving
one of us has to go
got one eye on the super group up on the
hill
and the other on him
i think that's him telling me
to get lost
i'm not a big bull moose
but i'm gonna try to call his bluff
yeah
kind of jumped out of there
so i don't know i don't know who else is
in here but
i'm gonna pay attention
that's for sure
it's clear these bulls know something i
don't
the rules of moose battle
it's time to take bullwinkle to the
school of hard knocks
[Music]
the other bulls are primed for battle i
think we should throw the big rack on
for sure first because we don't want
them to get creamed right away
and i think that he'll have a chance
here
the big antler should make the other
bulls think twice about challenging
bulwing
but that's just the theory
things are about to get real
it's gonna be awesome time for a battle
oh here we go lenny here's your friend
i think i'll put him right here
right over the top of this rut pit
if that doesn't say bring it on i don't
know what does
here he comes all right hurry up hurry
up he's coming
first bull that shows up is lenny a 14
year old in his prime
if anybody's gonna kick my decoys butt
it's this guy
but here he comes he's coming over
[Music]
here we go here we go
this is face to face mobile moves versus
lenny
he comes in slower and slower is this
his tactic come in slow down put the
punch to him
yeah a little head sway i mean that's a
challenge if i ever seen it right there
staring him in the eye like this
he starts really sizing the bowl up and
i think he's gonna charge he's gonna
nail this thing
lowering his tines down he's looking at
him
he's walking around sizing him up
giving a big bull moose strut
now what mobile moose's body language is
saying is i'm not afraid give me some
more
lenny is showing him
look at this rack i'll tip it sideways
you can see all the times you can see
how big my spurs are
i think okay he's gonna get him from the
back side
keeps walking
stops
one final long look
[Music]
then
walks away
didn't want to engage
but he definitely gave him some pretty
gnarly body language pulled those ears
back
dipped his antler over
letting mobile moose know
he might be in trouble
noticed our decoys antlers are larger
than lenny's
maybe bullwinkle's too dominant
i have to take it to the next level
i move the decoy directly between the
bulls and gert
in the moose rut every bull moose wants
to be the closest to the cow in
estranged so this is like a direct
challenge
i've got another bowl on the scene
all right russell we've got uh
looks like walter he's
he's a number two
in the packaging
this could be a little different
we've got two balls approaching
then out of the blue lenny just wheels
around and challenges walter
[Music]
there's no contact just body language
and lenny puts walter in his place
i needed a lot
of the same things that my decoy is
doing just kind of held a set high
frozen and stared at walter so it makes
me wonder
if the decoy is too dominant
this gives me an idea
while lenny is still focused on walter i
downsize the decoys antlers
something's looking good
lenny might just think it's a different
bull
he's coming in hot
all right here we go moment of truth
[Music]
he's really sizing him up i think it's
right in the moose's root
kind of clash
oh they're coming in close as close as
it's ever been
what's he gonna do
just hit him with his antlers
he didn't know what to do but they get
antlers lenny bales right away he
probably didn't like the way
the little bull
moved after he got ahead kind of made an
odd sound
lenny had to assert his dominance i
think he's hardwired to challenge a
rival with the same antler size
it's just like a boxer that will only
fight another boxer in the same weight
class i mean how many taxidermy bulls
get to actually go head-to-head with a
live moose i think we made his history
today
now i need to test my antler size theory
in the wild
but i've lost a super crew and i mean
lost
[Music]
this is gonna be a long night
i just woke up to some breaking branches
out there and at first i thought it was
just the wind or something that's a
pretty good branch is it gonna be a
moose or a bear
we should um we should grab the thermal
binoculars
yeah they're right over here
okay
so there's
a couple moves out here
and some gum right by the desk
there's two
there's something this might be one
right wait a minute
that's not a moose that's not a
moose it's a
it's a lynx i think
[Music]
look at that guy move he's so graceful
totally hunting
the lynx is a cat only found in northern
forest
it spreads its toes as it walks
forming a natural snowshoe
they hunt at night
so seeing this is incredibly rare
[Music]
oh
there he goes he's gone just like that
i think i must be
right in the middle of the super group
right now
there's a bunch of boost right over here
moves right there big bull
it was moves big after that links
that this big big
bull moose had walked up right behind me
i think i am in the middle
of a boost super group in the middle
of the night and i'm not gonna get that
guys away
i think the best thing i can do right
now
get some rest when the stuff comes
so i'm up really early
and i just heard a big bull grunting
when i was laying in my tent so i jumped
up
and
it's just right over here somewhere
he's looking
right through me
then i realize he's got his eye on the
cow behind me
[Music]
she's kind of crawled into this kind of
tight
kind of thick area and he's trying to
get into her but his giant antlers are
too big to get in there
get in the thick timber and wait to
watch she'd come right by me and try to
hide in the same standard timber that i
was
all of a sudden i've got a cow in heat
and a very aggressive bull moose and
he's coming right at me it's a tight
situation and i have nowhere to go
[Music]
the cow is just getting more and more on
edge
she pins her ears back and she stomps at
me
okay i'll back up
and here comes the big bull on the other
side
now this guy's coming over to check me
out so i got to be on my toes
i think that
okay i'll back up
hang tight it's that moment of body
language
two mammals in a meadow i'm talking
moose with moose definitely an
adrenaline rush no doubt
[Music]
i turned back to where the cow was
but wait a minute how did she get over
here
[Music]
that's not the same cow
they're everywhere
[Music]
i'm in the middle of the super group
i've got one two three four
even over ten posts
with me right here i've got cows coming
from
i finally have infiltrated the super
group and they've actually accepted me
into the herd it's amazing and even the
king of the group the big bull has let
his guard down
but to be this close to this situation
is really once in a lifetime
it's taken every skill that i have to
get me to this point
but one false step could turn the herd
against me
something's happening over here
two balls right here
oh
they're it's two bulls and they're
moving fast
let me take let me take the camera from
you and then i'll just sneak in there
it's pretty thick let's take it from you
okay
okay
i've got two big bowls in front of me
now i'm looking straight down the barrel
and their antlers are the same size look
at that
oh this power's clash
[Applause]
this is ridiculous
that's when it hits me my experiment
with bullwinkle just played out
in the wild
two matched rivals battling it out to be
the super moose
[Music]
you just tell me you got that fight
that was insane that was insane
next year just like every year the
battle begins again
[Music]
[Music]
you